sí pues en méxico hay una crisis en
materia de identificación forense de
acuerdo a diagnósticos que ha realizado
por ejemplo el movimiento nacional por
nuestros desaparecidos en méxico hay 52
mil personas sin identificar que se
encuentran en centros jóvenes mjs en en
cementerios y cosas comunes que justo
tienen que ser identificados el problema
es que no existe todavía un banco
nacional de datos forenses como se
mencionó ayer el cual está contemplado
en la ley general en materia de
desaparición forzada la cual entró en
vigor en el año 2018 en méxico sin
embargo su implementación tiene un
retraso bastante significativo no la ley
crea diferentes programas de política
pública diferentes programas por ejemplo
de búsqueda de exhumación y bueno pues
estas herramientas que contempla la ley
general como el banco de datos forenses
pues deberían ceder a herramientas con
las que cuentan las autoridades para
intercambiar información sobre por
ejemplo por cuerpos que están en
semáforos en fosas comunes y pues así
continuar con los peritajes y labores de
investigación y de investigación y de
identificación de personas desaparecidas
en las diferentes entidades del país
méxico registra más de 90.000 casos de
personas desaparecidas desde el 64
cuando comenzaron los registros entre el
primero de diciembre de 2018 y el 30 de
junio del 2021 ya se reportaron 49 mil
500 personas desaparecidas y solo 28 mil
fueron localizadas qué pasó con las
demás cuánto pueden tardarse en las
condiciones actuales las
identificaciones forenses
sí bueno creo que lo importante que
primero está bien recordar que no
necesariamente todas las personas que
están desaparecidas en méxico se
encuentran fallecidas no también es
entrada muy importante fortalecer los
procesos de búsqueda en vida de las
personas que se encuentran desaparecidas
pero si también hay pues hay un rezago
el material de identificación forense
que se ha estado diciendo pues desde
hace varios años por parte por ejemplo
de organizaciones de la sociedad civil
de colectivos de familiares en búsqueda
y que pues es importante avanzar en esto
nos recordemos por ejemplo que el 30 de
agosto se anunció ya o se presentó a las
personas que van a integrar el mecanismo
extraordinario de identificación forense
el cual es un mecanismo que se va a
encargar de avanzar en en los retos que
hay en materia de identificación de
personas no sobre todo en tratar de
identificar a las 50.000 personas
cuyo que hay un rezago en materia de
identificación y que pues bueno
esperemos que tenga resultados adecuados